you've got to be about the business of
making
friends and getting some community in
your life and getting some
accountability and some men in your life
that you trust that can speak into your
life a dear friend of mine that spoke to
my wedding who's a a
pastor uh I I called him too and okay
but listen he he doesn't get to be your
therapist he gets to be your friend yeah
he gets to refer you and you have to be
very intentional about asking him I need
referrals to
professionals um cuz I need you as my
friend what does that mean he needs to
hold the right to call you really stupid
like what you're doing is dumb or what
you're doing isn't healthy or get off
the couch we're going running or
whatever we're going to the gym right
now he needs to preserve that and you
need to go do hard therapy with a
professional therapist and there's a
powerful different
difference